i remember aged about 13
my dad was at the hospital i was at home
with the other kids and he phoned me to
say
your mum's not gonna make it
and then he said can you tell the others
and that was pretty tough
for a 13 year old to try to contemplate
[Music]
well i grew up in a little place called
oxted
in surrey my dad was a tool maker so he
worked on the factory floor all of his
life
and i remember distinctly that he would
go to work
eight o'clock in the morning come back
at five o'clock
have his tea and then go back to work
six o'clock till ten o'clock in the
evening five days a week so
that was pretty tough on him my mum was
a
nurse before she had children and then
she
um she had a disease that she got when
she was 11 stills disease
which is where your immune system turns
in on itself she was given steroids
which
were new at the time nobody knew much
about steroids
and whereas she'd been told by the time
she was 20 she wouldn't have children
she wouldn't be able to walk the
steroids meant that she had four
children
and she could walk in her 20s but the
steroids and the stills disease
over the years took a terrible toll on
her i remember
aged about 13 my dad was at the hospital
i was at home
with the other kids and he phoned me to
say your mum's not gonna
make it and then he said
can you tell the others and that was
pretty tough
for a 13 year old to try to contemplate
as it happens mum did make it and
she lived with the illness
for a long time but eventually it meant
that
she was unable to walk unable
really to talk she had her leg amputated
and she couldn't do anything unassisted
and that was really tough i think those
two things
the sort of factory floor worker that my
dad was
um and his strong labor views and my
mum's absolute devotion to the nhs
impacted on me and certainly shaped my
politics as a young person and
i joined the labour party just as soon
as i could age 16.
originally i was so into politics that i
thought i wanted to go into politics i
think
my dad and others thought that law was
going to be a much better
profession to go into so i went off to
leeds university
it was an exciting place to be we were
out and about the whole time
i studied law we sort of worked hard and
played hard
and it was whilst i was at leeds that i
started to study and to understand
international
human rights law which in the end guided
me into
my career you became the eventually
became the director of um
public prosecutions um is there any work
from that time that you're particularly
proud of now
the stephen lawrence case stephen as
everybody knows was
murdered in racially charged
circumstances
and for many years doreen lawrence who i
worked with at the time now
a friend and in fact an adviser to me as
leader of labour party
dory never gave up on justice for
stephen and eventually when i was
director of public prosecutions
there was a breakthrough with new
evidence new techniques in dna
new evidence about fibers that clothed
leave
on the scene of the crime and we were
able to prosecute
two of those responsible for stephen's
murder and they're now
in prison and for to see the degree of
justice for
dorian and the family was very very
impactful on me
the other case that um i remember
profoundly was
cases involving violence against women
and girls i was struck by
just how prevalent violence against
women and girls was domestic violence
domestic abuse sexual violence
and also the more time i spent as
the director of public prosecutions the
more i came to think that the criminal
justice system was not set up
to deal with violence against women and
girls at all well and some of the stuff
we looked at
was obvious nine out of ten
women and girls who experience abuse or
violence whether it's at home
or in the street in public
don't come forward to report it to the
police nine out of ten
and the more we chipped away at this the
more obvious it became
that there was some real stumbling
blocks along the way it's pretty unusual
for someone who's been through an
experience like that to want to walk
into a police station and therefore
we worked with others in the field on
sexual assault referral clinics
where women girls could go to a hospital
setting for example to report what had
happened to them
in the five years that i was there we
set about those
changes i became convinced that the
criminal justice system needed
pretty radical change and needed to be
much more focused
on victims you know some of these issues
have been
there for a very very long time and
some of the um provisions i thought
ought to be in the law when i was
director of public prosecution so that's
2008 through to 2013
have still not been done and that's a
huge huge frustration
you actually became a leader in lockdown
and that must have been
an incredibly strange time for you and
personally
it was very odd to become leader of
labour party during lockdown
nearly 12 months into me being later in
the labour party
and i still haven't done a speech to a
live audience
every speech i've done has been down the
barrel of a camera
and that is deeply deeply frustrating i
think it has made the job harder because
without being out and about in you know
town centres in communities in
businesses where you can talk to people
close up
have the sort of conversations that you
would normally have
without the restrictions it is much much
harder i
feel very much like i want to sort of
take the mask off and
and open the throttle and i haven't been
able to for the
12 months or so i've been leader
obviously we've got to live with
restrictions for a bit longer but the
sooner
um i can get out there to live audiences
um to seeing people in their communities
in the ordinary way
the better it will be from my point of
view at times
some people on the left of your party
have accused you of not criticizing the
government enough
during this pandemic do you think that's
fair
i said when i took over as labour leader
that i would offer a constructive
opposition and i did that because
my strong view then and it's my view now
is that in a pandemic when a virus like
this comes along
which has now taken what 126 000 deaths
most people think first and foremost
about their family
and they worry about the health of their
family and their friends
and in those circumstances most people
want the government to get it right i
think it's right to support the
government where they get it
right right to criticize where they get
it
wrong and you know half of the people
have criticized me for supporting the
government at all
half of them half of people have
criticized me for
for criticizing the government so
something tells me that
we probably just got the balance about
right
what do you do for fun but we know boris
likes to build model boxes
uh what do you do no model buses for me
i've got i think two major outlets and
things that happened at home for me
the first is our kids we've got a 10
year old girl and a 12 year old boy they
are
fantastic they're my lifeline the other
thing is
i love football and i play football
at least once a week twice if i can not
during the pandemic of course
i watch football whenever i can and i'm
a season ticket holder at arsenal
and so on match day when i can go meet
our friends
in the pub for a pint and a pizza and go
to the game
and so my children and football are my
fantastic release from my job
what do you what are we feeling about
his team
despite the results because we're
fighting
to get into the top half of the table
just at the moment despite the results
i'm optimistic and i'm particularly
optimistic about the really new
young players that are coming through
you know we got sucker
smith rowe martinelli fantastic
new players breaking through young
players breaking through
and famously we've seen that picture of
matt hancock playing football um are you
a better player than mike hancock i've
never played against matt
um so i'll leave that for others to
judge
in my head i'm still a box-to-box
midfield player
um all the guys i play with would laugh
at that now and text me
and say yak here in your head
are you pro var or anti-var oh i
quite like var um you know this is the
lawyer of me
i quite like the right decision um
although you know
as ever uh it depends who's playing i
don't know if you've seen you've kind of
become a meme
online as well but have you seen this
image here i have
i think that was one answer that boris
johnson was giving me and i was thinking
oh no the prime minister
goes this way he goes that way he
doesn't answer the question and that
ends up with
reactions from me on my face thinking
for heaven's sake
answer uh the question
why should the young people who are
watching this video right now
decide that they want kirst stormer as
their next prime minister
because i want things to change i think
we need to change for the better and
coming out this pandemic we've got the
choice
go back to what we had before which i
think was broken
or go forward to something better and
for young people this is hugely
important because the last 10 years have
been a real struggle so
firstly because i want to change things
change things for the better
second things i want to empower young
people i don't want to be the
spokesperson for young people that's
completely wrong
i want young people to be able to speak
for themselves and to be empowered
to do so so young people for change but
young people to speak for themselves and
to be
empowered i think that is far more
important and what i look forward to
is the day when young people watching
this are in the position to take the
decisions i take
that other people take and the sooner
the better
i got this job and i had to put a budget
together in i think it was about three
weeks
and i at that moment i mean i remember
those three weeks were obviously really
busy and i thought that would be the
hardest thing that i'd ever have to do
in my professional life and it turned
out that that's probably the easiest
thing i've had to do
in the six months or so that i've had
the job